[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai des comportements bas
bombardements barret j'ai des
comportements barre
beldan ça j'ai des comportements pareils
j'ai envie de faire
j'ai des comportements bas
c
p
[Musique]
m
je vous demande par le temps
je teste de toutes les castes et laissez
moi faire
j'ai créé à l'égaler la faire
c'est moi très haut
comparé deux mandats
fortement bas
j'ai des comportements balle
je remplis de guerre
et j'ai des comportements voix
il est quand même à la vigne mais
mélanie
regardez
[Musique]
c
après tout ce qu'on a mais
gagné
je crains des galets l'apéro les émois
créé
gk légale et la peur
les mois pairs bombardements barret j'ai
des comportements d'arrêt
je suis dans mon sport de combat
j'ai des comptoirs de lamballe
mais compromet les oscars
j'ai des cours d'eau
j'ai des comportements
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'en connais
combat
j'ai des comportements
celui-là mon comportement m'a gêné
comportement bas
mécontent belle adore ça j'ai des
comportements pareils
j'ai des comportements bavay
chantons tous merci
c'est exceptionnel et on a un qui va qui
fait que je sois là ce soir c'est un
ferro à moi je vous le dit c'est à m
sila à m sila il est fou de toi voilà et
donc il va être comme un fou qu'ils
soient là soit c'est même lui qui nous a
fait découvrir des titres
[Applaudissements]
les nouvelles productrice et sans
rigoler elle me fait des fiches elle
travaillait alors avec mon ami stéphane
bern le pitch vous n'avez pas pu te
passe à côté cet été si la nouvelle
étoile montante de la pop urbaine grâce
à son titre comportement certifié single
d'or et sur toutes les ondes et nos
clips plume le top streaming depuis des
semaines
[Applaudissements]
maintenant on peut écrire un truc aussi
ringard sur la tête de ma mère elle
déchire aya nakamura merci d'abord été
remerciés ainsi intégrer l'école de
danse
[Applaudissements]
c'est beaucoup d'espoir